le spectacle auquel nous venons
d'assister dans notre assemblée est
assez consternant et je crois assez
grave pour notre démocratie nous sommes
sur un débat important attendu par des
dizaines de milliers de nos compatriotes
soignants ou autre ou famille de
soignants qui attendent ce débat sur la
réintégration usagée parfois des
services publics qui attendent ce débat
sur la réintégration des personnels
depuis ce débat il est d'autant plus
légitime messieurs les ministres que la
France est un des tout dernier pays en
Europe avec la Grèce je crois à ne pas
avoir encore réintégrer les personnels
soignants c'est anomalie mérite à
elle-même le débat que nous avons
aujourd'hui en voilà que la majorité là
pardon la minorité gouvernementale
particulièrement
particulièrement soyez respectueux de
chacun dans cet assemblée et pardon de
vous rappeler les réalités arithmétiques
l'ami la minorité se étant
particulièrement minoritaire ce soir a
été battue sur un amendement de
suppression et là c'est l'affolement
c'est l'affolement dans les groupes dans
les groupes renaissances et alliés et on
assiste depuis un des manœuvres
d'obstruction inacceptables manœuvre
d'obstruction avec une centaine
d'amendements déposés par les
parlementaires de la majorité sur un
amendement
une blague philippe Juvin et pire que ça
est plus grave que ça plus grave que ça
les ministres ce sont livrés eux-mêmes à
un exercice de d'obstruction au travail
parlementaire en déposant un amendement
c'est la première fois c'est sans doute
la première fois dans la 5e République
qu'un gouvernement se prête à un travail
d'obstruction pour empêcher l'Assemblée
nationale de poursuivre en sa mission
vous devriez effectivement avoir honte
monsieur les ministres de vous être
prêté à ce jeu voilà l'assemblée
si la majorité si la majorité
minoritaire si l'Assemblée nationale ne
vote pas comme vous le voulez ce n'est
pas à vous de vos lettres sont secours
respectez l'Assemblée nationale merci
Monsieur le